Оксамитові схили, з граційними вигинами,
льодовикові озера
та стрімкі річки.
Це гірський хребет Свидовець - один з найвищих в українських Карпатах.
Уже четвертий рік точаться суперечки щодо майбутнього цих гір:
зберегти ліси чи побудувати гірськолижний курорт на майже 30 тисяч осіб.
Сільська влада за будівництво.
Екологія, яка екологія? Що там екологія. Знайшли екологію.
Захисники лісів категорично проти.
Ми б хотіли, аби тут був заповідник.
А в місцевому лісгоспі нібито і проти…
Я  дуже категорично проти цього курорту, бо порушиться ландшафт природи нашого краю…
Однак сліди від вирубки лісу вже нагадують лижні траси.
Тим часом селяни сподіваються, що курорт поліпшить їхнє життя.
Так як на "Буковелі", була б робота, люди мали б стабільну роботу.
"Буковель" файно процвітає і люди файно… І дороги які файні зробили, все поробили…
Все залежить від інвестора, які у них плани на це.
Непроглядний туман укрив вершини Свидовецького хребта.
Для цієї місцини це звичне явище.
Це одне з найвологіших місць України, тут випадає  до двох тисяч мм опадів на рік,
що в три-чотири рази більше, ніж загалом по країні.
Це забезпечує водою не лише прилеглі села,
а й цІле Закарпаття і навіть частково сусідню Угорщину.
Будівництво не просто гірськолижного-курорту, а цілого містечка на 28 тисяч чоловік
повністю знищить цю унікальну екосистему, вважає Орест Дель Соль
- 52-річний громадський активіст та засновник руху Free Svydovets.
Вода, той дощ, що падає на Свидовець, забезпечує і Рахів, і  Тячів, і Хуст.
Тобто все Закарпаття залежить від масиву.
Люди думають, що це місцеві мають вирішувати,
а це проблема для всієї України і навіть міжнародна.
З подвір'я Ореста добре видно один з найвищих гірський хребетів українських Карпат.
Це Свидовець, 80 кілометрів…
Орест, француз за походженням, вже майже 30 років мешкає в Україні.
Серед гір  збудував дім, створив еко-ферму.
До нього як до захисника довкілля звернулися по допомогу селяни.
Відстоювати гори не просто.
Хоч офіційними замовниками будівництва курорту виступають
Тячівська та Рахівська райдержадміністрації, однак лобістом курорту є компанія "Скорзонера".
Її пов’язують з олігархом Ігорем Коломойським.
Люди, наближені до олігарха, вже володіють гірськолижним курортом "Буковель" в Карпатах.
У Свидівці ж, згідно з планами будівництва,  мають звести 60 готелів,
120 ресторанів, 23 підйомники та траси довжиною 230 кілометрів.
Запланований навіть власний аеродром та штучні озера - для постачання курорту водою.
Це все розписано на восьми сторінках у листі компанії  "Скорзонера"
до голови Рахівської держадміністрації від 2016 року.
Копії цих документів надали DW активісти руху FreeSvydovets.
Активісти регулярно моніторять, чи не ведеться підготовка до будівництва.
Нині їдуть до Ясінянського лісгоспу.
Понад 80% території запланованого курорту припадає на ці землі.
Ми зараз їдемо перевіряти, як іде господарювання у лісі.
Для нас важливо, аби природа тут залишилася якнайкраща.
Цей курорт планує рубати більше 400 га лісу і саме праліси. І проти цього ми боремося.
Екологи переконані, що та вирубка, яка планово здійснюється в лісгоспі,
вже підлаштована під майбутній курорт.
Тут, зокрема, рубали під лижні траси.
Ця карта публічна, це детальний план території,
який затвердила районна державна адміністрація уже три роки тому.
Тут буде велике озеро на 500 тисяч кубометрів,
і тут починається витяг, який йде на самий верх Свидовця.
З висоти справді проглядаються дороги під траси.
Хоча у місцевому лісгоспі це заперечують.
Це абсолютно не відповідає…
У нас навіть немає таких карт, аби подивитися, де будуть траси проходити.
Проводяться рубки - то це відношення не має.
Офіційню причиною вирубки тутешніх лісів називають шкідників.
Еколог Петро Тєстов дослідив не одне лісогосподарство і переконаний,
що за санітарною рубкою дуже легко приховати будь-які мотиви.
Адже довести, чи справді ліс був ушкоджений шкідниками вже після його рубки - неможливо.
Для того, щоб передати в лісовий фонд під інше цільове призначення,
треба рішення Кабміну міняти, а потім той, кому це передається, повинен компенсувати збитки.
Щоб прийняти це рішення, ітиметься про сотні гектарів, або і тисячі.
І одна річ, коли передається сторічний ліс,
інша - коли молоді лісові культури, які ніякої цінності не мають.
Цей ліс є зоною промислової рубки та місцем, де планують звести курорт.
А також частиною туристичного маршруту до витоків річки Чорна Тиса.
Втім, виглядає дорога аж ніяк не мальовничо.
Скрізь сліди варварського господарювання: повалені дерева,
рови від лісорубів та лисі верхівки гір.
Такі пейзажі в Карпатах трапляються дедалі частіше.
Ми би хотіли, аби тут був заповідник і аби люди розуміли,
що такі екологічні системи є унікальними і їх треба зберегти.
Головне - ми боремося проти олігарха Коломойського,
який думає, що за гроші можна побудувати ціле місто на 30 тисяч громадян.
Ми вважаємо, що бетонувати таке місце, де є дика природа, це недобре.
Аби показати, які наслідки для лісу матиме будівництво курорту,
активісти їдуть далі, до гірської дороги, що була збудована кілька років тому.
Через рубку в лісі змінився світловий і водний режим, і молодий ліс почав сохнути.
Цей шлях, з одного боку, з'єднує два віддалених села, але з іншого -
повністю збігається з інфраструктурними планами розбудови курорту.
Через цю дорогу ми почали боротися за цей курорт, бо ми розуміли,
що лісники рубають цей молодий ліс,
який ви бачите, з причини не лісогосподарства, а щоби допомогти курорту "Свидовець".
Через суди різних інстанцій активісти намагаються зупинити будівництво курорту,
розпорядження про яке дала місцева влада.
Причин чимало - це відсутність технічної документації плану території курорту.
Адже мапа, яка є у вільному доступі не містить деталей будівництва,
а отже, важко визначити, що і де буде збудовано.
І досі немає незалежної оцінки впливу на довкілля.
Обурює те, що підготовка до будівництва йде тихцем, без інформування людей.
Натомість вже півтора року касаційна скарга щодо Свидівця
чекає на розгляд у Верховному суді України.
Якщо в Україні не вдасться захистити гори,
група Free Svydovets звернеться до Європейського суду.
Ми раді, що звільнили начальника обласного лісогосподарства,
бо він кришував ці питання, так само як директор Ясінянського лісгоспу.
Він був пов'язаний з Шевченком, який керує "Буковелем".
Ми задоволені, що людей на державних посадах,
коли ті стають помічені в корупційних схемах, звільняють.
Але їх, щоправда, можуть повертати на посади. Це дивно, але так є.
Такі екологічні міркування зовсім не поділяє селищний голова села Чорна Тиса.
Бо вважає, що сучасний курорт оживить довколишні села:
люди почнуть заробляти гроші на місці, а отже, перестануть виїжджати на заробітки.
Згідно з планом інвесторів, курорт надасть до 5 тисяч робочих місць.
Якщо нічого немає, нічого не робиться.. Дивіться, дороги немає. Взагалі капець.
Якщо він не прийде, то це село завмре. Лишаться одні пенсіонери тут.
Я говорив з губернатором, і він сказав, що після виборів, після об'єднаної громади
А що далі буде, яка обстановка, один Бог знає..
Будівництво курорту наразі залежить від рішення голови Закарпатської ОДА.
І якщо попередник Геннадій Москаль був одним з головних лобістів курорту у Свидівці,
то нинішній - Олексій Петров, каже, що ще не вивчав детально план курорту.
Втім, буде відстоювати інтереси громади,
яка закидала його проханнями дати старт будівництву.
Дуже багато отримав відповідних зверненнь від громади Рахівського району,
де планується будівництво.
Звернення саме з підтримкою розбудови інфраструктурного проекту,
який дасть можливість створити нові робочі місця.
І стане туристичним магнітом для Закарпаття.
Із закликом звернути увагу на дотримання природоохоронної політики
до Кабміну та Верховної Ради нещодавно звернулися 26 європарламентарів.
Вони наголосили на проблемі незаконної вирубки лісів
та неналежного виконання Закону України "Про оцінку впливу на довкілля".
Збереження природи має стати пріоритетом для української влади,
наголошують у Європарламенті.
На це розраховують і активісти руху Free Svydovets.